nearly like i think most people in my
family like all generations live
near the same area like within an hour
drive yeah and that's really weird to
think about
now that everyone lives within like an
hour drive like generations of families
so i'm like wait did no one have the
idea to just like leave
i feel like as a kid as a kid you it's
like really it's a really like exotic
idea to
live somewhere else and be someone new
right but then i feel like you
underestimate
just how much you like comfort yeah yeah
like it it really takes a lot for
someone to be like
i'm going to live in a new country yeah
and even for those of us who live in
different countries
um i know you know there are a lot of
things about home that i'm sure you miss
and even even if you know you really
like the place that you live in there's
a lot of things you miss as well like
it's it's massive props to you know like
i think all three of our parents right
at least that you know had the balls to
be like
i'm just gonna go to this country i know
[ __ ] nothing about it yeah so
my parents took it pretty like easily
for me yeah because it's like thailand
to the uk
philippines to america yeah and mike has
japan to australia right like it's like
like i've always wanted like five
yeah my dna generations is like 100
british like there's no one in my family
right from any other country in any any
like way well because like you also like
you not only
well your parents not only moved from
the philippines to america
but they also moved to probably the most
like non
like friendly place for like non-white
people right
yeah so i was technically born in
bakersfield california because the labor
clock was ticking
but then as soon as i was born they went
to um
uh virginia and then i lived half my
life in a
place that honestly sounds like the
beginning of like an rpg game it's
called mechanicsville
it sounds like something in nino cooney
honestly yeah there's like a jlpg name
yeah and then i i i so starting village
mechanicsville
what was weird is like i had i didn't
even realize i had like this weird i
guess
almost country twain to my accent until
i came to the west coast
to las vegas and then people were
teasing of like the way i say y'all or
the fact i even say y'all
a lot um so i had to kind of like i
didn't realize that virginia they say
y'all
yeah because it doesn't because you look
at it on a map and it's like oh that's
nowhere near
this texas not the only place no but
like just someone who knows nothing
about america right like
when you hear y'all you immediately
think oh yeah texas
yeah i think southerner like yeah right
but like virginia's not even in the
south it's like kind of
halfway up all the way he's also like
kind of like the founding ground
so yeah but no one yeah but not most
people don't know no one knows that
except me
i like us history well really i like is
this barely any of it
that's true yeah
history is so [ __ ] confusing i went
through a weird period where i was
obsessed with your guys's history and
culture there's so much of it and
there's like so many bands that like i
love that none of my friends in the us
can relate to
like i think when we were at karaoke
garn was so surprised i was playing
kaiser chief i predicted right
yeah that doesn't seem like or take that
shine
like take that my just to give you like
my mom and her friends love take
the kind of demo that they have the
first time she was playing take that and
i saw the music video was like wow the
backstreet boys got really old
it's basically especially at the uk
backstreet boys for middle-aged women
who are married yeah
that's kind of like that target down
yeah yeah yeah
yeah but like that's the thing right
it's like it's not until you kind of
like
look deep into like the whole like us i
guess like
geography that you realize that oh just
because it's not in a particular area
it doesn't necessarily mean they don't
talk the same way right like i thought i
don't know i don't know what i thought
people in virginia sounded like i
thought maybe they sent it closer to
like people
from new york yeah i don't know i mean
like new york's kind of like its own
thing
i feel like the way like the some
americans are probably hearing this
right now and being like and cringing
because i feel like the way we talk
about american geography
is how we feel when we hear americans
talk about europe or something yeah yeah
i think like someone from the uk i i
think that
british accents and like where they're
laid out is 20 times more confusing
oh i think they are the u.s is so easy
to keep track of where someone's from
based on the accident in the uk
it's like oh uh this guy sounds
completely different to person like a
person sounds different from a b person
they could either be like two hours
apart or literally five minutes at a
different time yeah
because because what's what's confusing
about uk accents is that you can travel
a small amount of distance
and have a widely varied access well i
mean just in london there's like 20
different access
right and that's just a city yeah like
you know whereas in australia i think
australia's the only kind
english-speaking country that doesn't
have regional dialects or accents
they just have like degrees of like
strength yeah
but but that's not based on where you
are that's based on how far
off the coast you are like the further
the further inland you are the less you
are able to understand it's just an
aussie scale basically and you you scale
up
you scale up the further inland you go
it's like oh yeah you're definitely from
the inland if i can't understand what
the [ __ ] you're saying
because like you know like kevin for
example right he's from perth
which is all the way on the west coast
and i'm from the east coast
but if you ask someone who doesn't know
australian accent yeah you do something
we would say
exactly the same exactly the same yeah
that doesn't work in america at all like
in america you can clearly tell if
someone's from new york versus
california right pretty well yeah
like even like louisiana or like like i
don't know like just from texas to
california they just say like a lot
yeah i don't know and yeah i wonder did
your obsession with the uk
start with the crown is that why no
actually way before that really
yeah yeah yeah sorry interrupt you no no
it's cool harry potter
no actually yeah wait wait
you can normally pinpoint which show
gets people in the beatles
what was the start of your team face
did a song with black bubbles oh
i i don't know like is the click five
british
what the [ __ ] the question come on man
i feel like
what is it it's a basketball tv show
after you watch the crown
man can you look up the click five yeah
after you watch the crown you're like
are they british
i'm gonna learn welsh what yeah can you
say that
yeah never mind from massachusetts
i don't know who the hell it was i know
i know i just listened to a band
and then it just got me into british
music and then from there i just got
into british culture
i just happened to also be watching
harry potter at the time yeah but then
somewhere in there yeah but then you
watched the crown and you told connor i
was like
i love that you were like trying to like
speak welsh and i was like whoa yeah
no one does this because it was so
pretty like i was just like man
yeah thank you it is i don't know
everyone said no so many people like wow
it sounds disgusting and i'm like
really listen to it no i think i think
well sounds [ __ ] dope yeah i like
i i like welsh i don't know best flag
disgusting best flag
it's a just a [ __ ] epic it's just a
dragon
dragons